ya hemos visto un montón de veces lo que
significa bueno en la integral definida
o que representa en el eje de las equis
pero esta vez quiero que pensemos en
algo muy interesante
quiero que nos tomemos la integral ok de
fx de f de x de x es decir el área bajo
la curva de esta función fx pero en esta
ocasión en lugar de tomarme dos puntos
es decir tomarme la integral definida
desde el punto a hasta el punto b es
decir dos valores distintos de x bueno
pues esta vez quiero que nos tomemos
esta integral desde el mismo valor que
te parece
desde c hasta c es decir imagínate que
tenemos aquí al valor de s y bueno aquí
crees que sea igual esta integral es
decir que representa que es lo que tú
piensas que nos va a dar de resultado
esta integral y te voy a encargar que en
este momento pausa es el vídeo y que
pienses un poco en ello
bueno si nosotros lo queremos ver
representado aquí en esta gráfica si lo
queremos visualizar lo que queremos ver
es el área bajo la curva fx desde x
igual a cm hasta bueno x igual hace
bueno pues esta región si así lo podemos
llamar tiene una cierta altura que es
esta cierta altura que tenemos aquí que
por cierto es fcc ok
fcc pero él es su ancho bueno pues
realmente no tiene ancho porque no vamos
desde un punto hasta otro no vamos desde
sea hasta c + delta de equis o dicho de
otra manera desde sea hasta hace más un
pequeño cambio en x porque lo único que
estamos haciendo es tomarnos este valor
de c solamente estamos hablando del
punto cero y es que esto me da pie a
pensar que cuando yo hablo acerca de un
área lo que estoy pensando es cuánto
espacio en nuestra segunda dimensión me
estoy tomando pero en este caso estamos
hablando de algo de una dimensión es
decir de un segmento de línea y bueno
cuál es el área de un segmento de línea
pues un segmento de línea
tiene área y entonces está integral de
aquí va a ser igual a 0 y seguramente me
vas a decir bueno esto tiene mucho
sentido tiene mucha intuición detrás
quiero intentar encontrar el área de un
rectángulo a cuya altura esté fdc pero
su entre 0 por lo tanto el área va a ser
igual a cero esta es una forma que me
gusta mucho de pensar este el mismo
problema esto está muy padre pero sal
porque nos quieres enseñar esto cuál es
el punto de esto que estamos viendo pero
el punto es que cuando tú resuelvas
integrales más complejas o problemas más
difíciles que los que tenemos aquí
algunas veces reconocer esta expresión
te ayudará a simplificar oa reducir el
problema de integración de una manera
dramática o tú puedes trabajar una
integral para llegar a algo de este
estilo y entonces algunas cosas se
podrán cancelar o decir que sabemos que
esta integral vale cero